edward cullen han solo kill monger
Lestat what do all of these characters
have in common besides being heart
throbs they share a common ancestor the
Byronic hero brooding sensual violent a
little too single-minded the Byronic
hero has been a staple in literature
dating back to the 19th century but the
archetype is all over film television
even video games
I see Cloud Strife all sad and angsty
with your giant sword plucked what does
it mean to be a bionic hero and who
exactly was the man that helped create
this iconic archetype well let's get
into the myth the man and the literary
legacy according to Professor Peter L
source love author of the Byronic hero
types and prototypes and romantic
contraries the characteristic Byronic
hero has borrowed characteristics from
the gothic villain in his looks his
mysterious past and his secret sins and
from the man of feelings in his tender
sensibilities and in his undying
fidelity to the woman he loves but he is
more than these he is a romantic rebel
he chooses his values in open defiance
of the codes of society that's right you
defy the code of society by being sad
and hot and with your slightly
stalker-like tendencies we'll get into
that the bionic hero allowed for more
complicated male characters to form and
without him we miss out on the
development of the antihero but where
did the Byronic hero even come from a
very very bad boy named George Gordon
Byron aka Lord Byron himself born to an
absent father and a mercurial mother
Byron had a brilliant mind but had a
very deep complex about being born with
a misshapen foot he came in to weld
while young but was surrounded by such a
malevolent cast of characters in his
home life it makes the Dursleys
seem loving and supportive because of
the complex he developed around his work
foot
byron exercised excessively to make up
for what he saw as a flaw the other
thing he was excessive about was his
love of the ladies and the gents
enter Lady Caroline Lam England 1812 the
drama begins Caroline lamb wife of
future prime minister Lord Melbourne had
a very very messy love affair with Byron
that had several public dramatic moments
including her breaking a wineglass and
threatening to harm herself she
notoriously called Byron mad bad and
dangerous - no definitely a Gemini TMZ
would have lived for this the real
kicker king when lamb wrote her gothic
revenge novel glenarvan which basically
frames Byron as a vampiric figure who
through his incredible magnetism
attracts women only to suck out their
strength by stealing their hearts and
taking their innocence glenarvan was
basically a tell-all book under the
guise of fiction with very clear
allusions to real people allusions that
were so obvious that it ended lambs
position in social society forever but
the public loved it and the main villain
that Byron inspired Clarence de Ruthven
aka Lord glenarvan was deliciously messy
it was from this story by land that we
get the first Byronic hero not written
from Byron's point of view and lo the
Byronic floodgates opened up gothic and
romantic fiction of the 19th and 20th
centuries ate this up the Bronte's du ma
Hugo LaRue hell even Ian Fleming's James
Bond is pretty Bionic debate me in the
comments so why is this version of our
romantic hero so popular there are many
kinds of Bionic heroes but for the sake
of everyone we're gonna split them into
two groups the Gothic and the romantic
gothic novels which often blend together
horror and romance feature dark hopeless
figures tormented by a wrong done to
them that makes up their entire
existence they can sometimes be villains
but are often anti here
possessing some sort of complex
emotional backstory that is meant to be
sympathetic some famous examples are
Victor Frankenstein and Frankenstein's
monster
Captain Ahab from Moby Dick Eric from
The Phantom of the Opera Edmond Dantes
from The Count of Monte Cristo and
Megamind from DreamWorks is Megamind
again today me in the comments in
romance literature aka romance
literature of the 19th century as
opposed to the romance genre we know
today in those the hero is a solitary
figure who seeks to live out their life
in isolation but is pulled into society
against their will they have a mixture
of monsters or darker appearance yet
alluring personalities they'll scream
and yell at you at one moment and then
look longingly into your eyes and the
other which what do you think about it
is kind of a red flag popular versions
of this archetype are Rochester from
Jane Eyre he cliff from withering
Heights and pretty much any vampire in
fiction who was ever sad about being a
vampire they love to brood in the sad
boy vs. vengeance boy a Venn diagram
what connects them is the moral grey
that makes you as the reader empathize
with their situation the creature from
Frankenstein is reacting to the cruel
world that created him and Victor wild
reckless was genuinely frightened by
what he had created and while he was
neglectful he didn't deserve to have his
entire family slaughtered at von Dante's
his desire for revenge after spending 14
years in a French prison after being
framed for a crime he did not commit is
very understandable however does it
actually justify the innocent lives lost
in the crossfire of said revenge quest
Claude Frollo from Victor Hugo's 1831
novel The Hunchback of Notre Dom starts
off as a good man who loves his adoptive
son and younger brother but is gripped
by a lust for a woman he cannot have and
does
I want him explicitly and it tips him
into madness quicker than you can say
I'm losing to a bird Heathcliff is such
a compelling romantic lead because the
text makes it clear that he was forced
into becoming a bitter hateful man by
the society around him but his deep
toxic love for Katherine and his lack of
begging for sympathy actually makes the
reader drawn to him Rochester has this
deep love for Jane and treats the people
around him overall very kindly but he
can still lock his mentally ill wife up
in an attic and shame her for being sick
biron he had this huge capacity for love
intelligence and understood the great
beauty in the world but he was also
chaotic and emotionally aloof he was the
baddest bad boy and the appeal of that
character is that misguided hope that
one day you will be the one that you
might change him as literary genre
critic Konrad aqua lena eloquently put
it the Byronic hero bears the dual
markings of both villain and victim he
is a fallen creature in his own right a
dark angel bringing both love and death
yearning for redemption and ultimately
finding none Erik the titular phantom
from Gaston Leroux's Phantom of the
Opera is a talented man whose lifetime
of pain has forced him to resort to
extreme means in order to be loved by
someone like building a torture chamber
in his guest bedroom did Eric know he
was rich in EM holes 1919 novel the
Sheik not only is our hero abusive and
tortured which I am putting mildly he
breaks his victims so hard she totally
falls in love with him by the end but
don't worry he feels bad about it
eventually this novel though incredibly
problematic create a paradigm shift for
the Byronic hero and romance in general
before this if a woman is defiled she
can only regain her purity through death
but this time
it's a happy ending with the guy who
kidnapped her progress though not as hot
of a commodity in the mid 20th century
the late 20th century saw a huge
resurgence in the popularity of the
Byronic hero there was the emergence of
the bodice for her sub-genre of romance
novels like 1972's the flame and the
flower which is considered the first
bodice Ripper romance and revolutionized
the modern romance genre and it has a
dynamic between the two romantic leads
that is very influenced by the chic then
there's more recent characters like
Twilight's Edward Cullen and his
spiritual cousin Christian Grey yeah I
know but he's a really popular example
so he had to talk about him he is very
Bionic Gray has severe childhood
emotional and sexual trauma that keeps
him from being able to form healthy
sexual or romantic relationships with
the women he respects or able to respect
women period but don't worry
in comes bright-eyed virgin honest taja
Steele whom he gasps slides abuses and
makes cry a lot
but you know she wants to change him and
by the end of the thousand plus
agonizing journey she succeeds and he's
healed now haha see the Sheik is um
really influential all of these
characters are different from the more
traditional upbeat capital our romantic
hero and that they are primarily shaped
and motivated by their traumas past and
present one might note that
overwhelmingly these characters are male
and white but more recently we see more
female characters who possess some
Byronic qualities faith from Buffy the
Vampire Slayer
Regina from Once Upon a Time Olivia Pope
from scandal Katra from Shira but those
characters are punished more by both the
audience and the writers for their
nature it tends not to be framed with
the same seductive quality
sometimes the alluring aspect of female
and non-white Byronic characters is
seeing them have the freedom to be more
complex than just idealize one note
types of representation at our Stein
argues that catherine earnshaw from
weathering heights and you stacy a vibe
from the return of the native by thomas
hardy our Byronic heroes because of
their quote rebellion against a
conventional society that stifles
individuality and that these veronik
heroines take on the characteristics of
the rebellious ambitious narcissistic
individualistic and ultimately
self-destructive Byronic male however
both these characters are killed off and
those who are not end up finding their
way back to traditional female values
whatever that means this reflects the
reality for a lot of women throughout
history who were brilliant but were
considered too loud may have been
dismissed as hysterical were queer were
women of color and didn't conduct
themselves as ladies a major difference
between the male and female variants at
least in the 19th century is that these
female characters are not allowed to be
romanticized in the same way men are
Bionic heroes are unlikable on purpose
but there will always be a privilege of
being white male and rich that allows
these characters to be so awful and get
away with it do you think Rochester
would be able to get away with keeping
his wife in the Attic for the lulz and
still be considered the romantic lead
Byron died at 36 years old from an
illness exacerbated by the then common
practice of bloodletting I'll let you
google that his tragic death at a young
age made him a hero the world mourned
him in the same way people mourned
Hendrix Cobain Joplin Winehouse the
sudden death of a great artistic genius
who burned so hotly and wildly that was
no shock at all that he burned out so
quickly but in a delightful touch of
irony one of the greatest legacies of
Byron's life was his daughter
ada Lovelace called one of the first
computer programmers and considered by
many to be as much or it's not more of a
genius than her father Byron can be
noted as one of the most influential
authors and our
of his time according to British
literature professor and Roy elf and
mine Byron is not just an author but an
unprecedented cultural phenomenon his
work not only affects the novel poetry
and drama but fashioned social manners
erotic experience and gender roles the
Byronic hero has much in common with the
broader concept of the antihero
tormented by forces beyond their control
with a sharp wit that they have
developed in order to cope with whatever
monstrous thing that is innate to them
now this damage does not make them good
there is no good reason to emotionally
manipulate people or lock people in
attics or kidnap young singers and put
them into your torture guest room leave
nice people alone no means no Byron's
but the cruel circumstances of fate make
them tragic especially when the story
makes it clear that otherwise they may
have actually been someone capable of
true emotional growth LaRue even ends
his phantom of the opera' thusly with an
ordinary face he would have been one of
the noblest members of the human race he
had a heart great enough to hold the
Empire of the world and in the end he
had to be content with a cellar all of
the tortured romantic bad boys of
literature film and television have a
little bit of Byron in them so the next
time you get deep in your fields for
kylo Ren cheer on the redemption Arc of
Prince Zuko or secretly pop on toilet
for the 200th time maybe pulling out to
Lord Byron to whom we owe all of this
angsty goodness to or James Dean either
one will do yikes
nah I'll advice to a church this is my
fight song Take Back my life song all
that work for two life